لبس لبس يا عريس مالك زعلان لبس لبس يا
عريس مالك زعلان هذا مجدي واليوم عرسه
وهذه خطيبته فاطمه هما يستعدان ليوم
زفافهما في مخيم الزعتري للاجئين بالاردن
وكان اتخاذ هذا القرار صعبا سوريا يعني كل
ما اقول همي بدي ارجع على سوريا ما تخليني
رحله ثلاث شباب ما بدهاش تخسر
زياده يعني خلص
الشغله يعني ما في داعي انه نرجع سوريا
نرجع مشان قاتل مثلا او شيء عندي والدتي
يعني بتسوى الدنيا وما فيها وما بخلي يعني
انه تنز لها دمعه مشان شغله فاضيه
او يعني وقررنا عيله كامله انه
اتجوز ويعني وقنع وي يعني عالم كثير قنعتي
انه اتجوز احسن ما تروح على سوريا او شيء
يعني
[تصفيق]
الع مجدي عاطل عن العمل من ريف دمشق لا
يملك الكثير ليقدمه ولهذا احتاج لمساعده
اصدقائه وعائلته في دفع تكاليف حفل الزفاف
بهذا المخيم
واخواته واسرته زواج خواته كل واحد تبرع
له بشغله يقام نحو عر حفلات زفاف في مخيم
الزعتري كل اسبوع بالنسبه لهؤلاء اللاجئين
انها وسيله للتمتع بحياه طبيعيه في مثل
هذه الظروف فرحان
وخي زعلانه على اهلي تركت
اهلي وفرحانه لان مع اللي انا النقد حلمي
بالنسبه لبنتي انه الله يوفقها هي وجوزها
بالاول وبالثاني اني حابه انه اليوم جوزت
بنتي بكره انه يقولوا انه بدنا نرجع على
سوريا ويكملوا حياتهم هناك ويقول مجدي انه
سيبقى هنا للبحث عن وظيفه وسيبدا حياه
جديده مع عروسته على امل العوده الى
سوريا بتعرف